une question raté pmp mathieu nom cyrill
sinon le veille c'est un peu beaucoup de
femmes l'admirent mme simone veil parce
que la libérer les femmes qui a enfin pu
être maîtres de leur corps et en plus
elle a un passé tellement incroyable
c'est qu'il grand père paul mais ne sont
à venir
ah et puis et puis moi en carotte lemay
mars 2017 ou cyril va laisser présenter
les missions à l'étranger c'est k way y
avec jessica qui ma personne rigole à
mes vannes il ya autre chauffeur de
salle c'est quoi ce bazar et où j'ai
réussi je ne sais pas comment à faire un
million trois cent cinquante mille
téléspectateurs le lendemain matin ce
qui n'était pas peu dire
donc voilà j'ai sauvé les meubles
j'aimerais bien vous dire que j'aimerais
avoir la longévité de michel drucker
mais ça c'est pas gagné on a encore du
chemin à faire on les femmes
et sinon sur les planches d'un théâtre
où
[Musique]
en train de faire du buzz être sur une
plage de corse
et sinon faire de toute manière ce chêne
clair je pense le mieux un grand tokyo
cfm levin